she must have been dripping from
dripping that butter dip had it on the
right we've got drapes
[Music]
yeah oh where's that Nickelodeon I think
so
yeah
or maybe car Network
yeah car network is it for a specific
show no I it's and no I don't think so I
think I think it's the car Network comes
up yeah I think it's kind of maybe
Johnny Bravo is misogynistic in it
it was the one Wham yeah yeah you
couldn't really get away from Kylie
Network
nah bro I know it was it and I only had
it at my dad's house I remember so my
voice is marked today
when you had at my dad's house so I
would just binge it yeah binge Cartoon
Network bro and then especially like the
new age stuff Adventure Time Regular
Show yeah dumb ball yeah bro those shows
slap I was more in the the Retro times
like the early 90s that was that was my
bag like oh the Powerpuff Girls
Powerpuff Girls Cow and Chicken Courage
the Cowardly bloody bro yeah a running
Stimpy I think I was Boomerang yeah
bro Teen Titans went hard
whose voice is that
um it sounds like Patrick yeah it might
be a lot like that it might be it might
be it might be I don't remember that one
Dexter's Lab was it
um
everyone knows that bro
I was um
she's got like the gloves and the the
apron that's Cowin chicken Cow and
Chicken you can you can't see the top
half of them yeah but I'm thinking about
the body she had like her she was
wearing gloves and had like a face
that's all I remember yeah yeah you
could see the Dad's face I think but you
could never see the mums I can't
remember you know you couldn't see the
moms I know you couldn't see their moms
for sure yeah Dexter's mom
what did Texas bomb look like again I
can't remember
did she was she she had a bob shut up
Ginger Ginger thing in it yeah
she has some pigs on her as well bro
itsy bitsy yeah it didn't make sense
Yeah Yeah
from John Bro was she wearing heels as
well she had their boots yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah bro yeah pull her up man
bro
the Mez secretary and Powerpuff Girls
the mess I don't remember oh my days bro
the man was a pervert and that Monaco
the man was a pervert bro oh this one
with a big hat Bella Miss Bellum big
hair yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah oh
Miss Bellum yeah Bodied
yeah I don't think they make sense bro
bro come on bro yeah Miss Bellum was
Langston come on bro Miss Pelham was leg
bro
that's jokes yeah that's jokes what's
that say Dojo trust it to be Doja cat
let's see that though wait
I'll swear bad not bad not bad it's
given it looks like I spice a little
yeah Miss Bellum was banging bro
anyway guys anyway let's go let's go on
with the episode and the question of the
week which I only realized today that
I've done this question before but we
move when's the most inappropriate time
you've laughed uncontrollably and I've
got a handful of replies so we run them
um a special needs girl in my class
punched a Handler in the face over a
pencil
ah bro I mean it's inappropriate time to
laugh right a special needs girl it's
very inappropriate pencil I'm not
dealing with that like
I remember the teacher's assistants
helping with the special needs kids in
my school it was just long I don't
remember any of that to be fair it was
just long bro it just seemed long
it does sound and seem long to be fair
yeah when my dad reached back whilst
driving to choke me out because I was
being loud and annoying
he stopped and he was laughing
uncontrollably yeah mother would have
murdered me he would have murdered us
skirt skirt yeah yeah yeah might have
threatened to kill us one time I
remember he opened the door on the
motorway he did what yeah his door his
door to jump out so the car was just the
car would have just got done what it
done what yeah he got his leg out like
that I was like six I was scared what
happened bro why why why the threat
we're [__] around I can't remember
seeing your brother yeah me and my
brother I remember my mum was in there
as well and everyone was walking around
everyone was just pissing him off and I
can't obviously I was young young I
don't really remember what happened but
I remember my dad was just it was
something along the lines I walk around
and find out yeah and then I just
remember him we were on the M1 I said
just opened the door just open the
driver's side door and put his foot out
I'm on a like you man actually don't
think I won't just jump out and fend for
yourselves bro what he you man must have
been oh oh
my dad got pissed off easy he's taking
his own life from his family yeah wow
yeah yeah yeah that's that's on her own
characteristic for my dad so I'm
assuming he was joking because it's very
out of character my mum would do that
every Tuesday
I'd say less that's jokes all right um
when's the most inappropriate time
you've laughed uncontrollably at my
grandfather's funeral my aunt tried to
jump in the gray grave and no one
stopped her can you imagine Bravo people
need to chill have you been to a funeral
before
I've only been to one funeral I think I
told you it was like two years ago I was
like my
step granddad's funeral okay and I
remember telling you because
because she seemed boring oh okay he's
just like I'm saying um when the people
come up and speak about the life and
stabilities eulogies the eulogies
but uh
he was a lovely guy who did Jesus were
bored I'll swear and all I remember
thinking is my eulogies cannot bang like
this yeah yeah yeah they cannot bang
like this I refuse for them to bang like
this because this is boring me my friend
my close friends and family can't speak
about my life like this yeah it's just
boring me all they're talking about is
work and Cricket that's all I want to
talk about oh God
and his kids [__] us all of that tell me
the exciting stuff yeah I think I've
only I think I know I've only been to
one funeral and I was probably in year I
think I was in my second year of uni it
was my friend's
dad that passed away I think I remember
talking about one here and he had like
an open he had open-ish costume
it was a jar bro so it wasn't like the
whole thing went off I think it was one
of them was the the lid is on but
slanted so you can see the face you just
see the face yeah Jesus yeah I remember
walking through it yeah we all had to
like go in and go out to walk around I I
remember going in
going around the casket but I remember
looking back at my boys to see what
their reactions are I've seen the face
and I nearly knocked the casket I was
petrified and I scurried out that's my
one and only um bro nah I'm not scared
I'm not trying to do it I I actually
don't think I can handle an open gasket
people seem to normalize it a little bit
but like that's a that's a real dead
person yes a lot I don't think I can
handle it same bro same I feel like I've
done it once and it's it was weird as
hell he was black yeah he did look white
I don't really remember I don't think so
but he did look a little bit pit and he
was a big tall guy so he looked you
could tell he was deflated a little bit
it was no no no no no no no it's weird
no no like maybe six three
yeah but he was he didn't look the same
it just looked shriveled a little bit
nope see stuff like that yeah no no
especially if that was my dad
I couldn't have open casket for my
parents I could never I don't think I
wouldn't stomach her I don't know
something none of it I don't give a
stomach at all anyway let's move on yeah
yeah it's getting very morbid
um
inappropriate time your life um
uncontrollably whilst my sister was
getting baptized the priest was
stuttering while preaching damn I don't
know how priests do it what starter in
general no just just get through it
without stuttering because sometimes
they do off the Dome when they
especially when they do like the the
pleasure this is African style prayers
well you say Eggman like nine times yeah
yeah bro practice I guess yeah
when you're when you just when you just
qualify yeah yeah your first year how do
you run bars like that on your first
trip first shift
yeah like oh and how does everyone know
when to say Amen
I guess it's just built in because I
just get so awkward you man let me just
get into it I don't know I don't know
how you man feel
I know you might feel yeah when we're at
Gatherings yeah and we're doing prayers
yeah and these men are like
and then there's a sequence to it and
it's like it goes long paragraph no one
says [__] then there's a short little
I know
what
and they're like okay and then 10
seconds everyone's like oh man you're
like the [__]
that's the only time I know can I get an
amen bro and then you say amen yeah and
then it's Amen but these men are just
spitting and everyone's like amen amen
and then sometimes it gets a bit Rowdy
yeah yeah and it's like Eminem
sometimes it gets row to you bro and
that's when the that's when the
processing is bad yeah that's when the
prison is back yeah when it's like
Just Go With It everyone's I don't know
and then when the aunties get the
hankies out he's in his bag when he's
not speaking tongues yeah yeah he knows
he's qualified that day he's qualified
his voice gets raspy yeah yeah that's
when everyone loses their [__] that's a
joke I didn't know there's a passage in
the Bible okay it goes like as I walk
through the valley of the shadow of
death I just thought of Gangsta's
Paradise straight away yeah straight
after it yeah there's no way I'm sitting
with a straight face and someone's
saying that literally and then without I
take a look at my life and realize
there's nothing left
in so long
[Laughter]
those jokes
that's jokes say
um all right I've got a few more
my friend's granddad's birthday he blew
out the candles and wished for no more
birthdays oh God
he was tired bro bro he was tired
um at my auntie's funeral she was too
big for the casket so they had her
thrown on a table like a pig at a feast
the only thing that was missing was the
Apple in her mouth
nah what kind of barbaric funerals is
man that's you on a table
it's a spread out just nah bro
I can't pay my respecter neither could I
I'm not paying any respects for that
respect her first and foremost before I
pay my respect my family yeah wow that's
on a table like a pig out of feet
that's descriptive boy
oh [__]
oh God that's jokes
wow
um I was called to a meeting at my son's
school because he body slammed another
child
damn I lie uh okay copper more when my
dad got slapped by a 67 year old mother
yeah that will spin you yeah because
like where's the power yeah yeah yeah
who's really in control yeah because
you've been talking [__] to me for years
yeah I've just seen you guys some frail
or a woman pumped you up twice
yeah you can't talk to me like that
anymore yes because I would just call
grammar on you facts I might as well
smack you myself because you ain't gonna
do [__] yeah I'm not gonna handle you
yeah wow all right last one uh during
sex he bust hella quick and said whose
[__] is this I laughed and said clearly
not yours
tough that's really bad and she laughed
uncontrollably clear not yours and then
proceeded that's just like oh God laugh
yeah and you know when you leave it in
and they laugh and you can feel it you
can feel it on there and because you're
not hard anymore it's just pushing
yourself yeah it's just sliding you're
sloppy tool out
and she lost some more come on oh God oh
God you already know you're in the group
chat your world is crumbling your whole
world is crumbling that there and you
can hear yourself in the group chat and
you're not in the close friends anymore
definitely not definitely not
yeah but anyway welcome to the show guys
welcome guys what's up man your boys are
here yes sir and um we're back
I'm feeling juicy this episode yeah I I
am me and REM just yeah you took a
little took some um stimulants and um
yeah it's just we took some nootropics
and I'm feeling good bro I'm not feeling
jittery or anything like that or
something I'm just feeling focused I'm
laser focused good so guys if you want
to focus up as well head on over to
patreon.com shits and gigs
and what we're gonna do right
so this is what it looks like so you've
got the whole world
and then there's a tiny little
section of the population that you Zone
in on
and then
like imagine like a space satellite
telescope and it goes
and it goes to street view and only here
it's it's
off the camp that's the that's the camp
right that's where we're at and we're
like what's going on in there and then
they have to get other satellites down
to like and there's a general somewhere
that's like focus focus and it's
ever survivors everyone's vibing good
time yeah yeah and then all you can hear
is just like
and you're like whoa
you know what's good yeah Chief clapping
look what's going on in there it's just
it's just the cult baby yeah yeah it's a
cold baby Fest exactly and that's 24 7.
and that's where you guys need to that's
where you need to do that's where you
need to be guys so if you want to be
there cold baby Fest 2024
yeah all year round 24 7. it's just
gonna be Vibes bro
before we set that up if you want to
prepare yourself there's nearly like
four years worth of content over there
you can binge bingy bingy bingy and you
can hop on the Discord Channel and just
chat just chat about all the fun [__]
we're going to do at Cold baby Fest
2024. so it's going to be a vibes
apparently Charli XCX is is confirmed
hey
marshmallow marshmallows DJ in he's DJ
in
um helmetless yeah facts yeah it's going
to be flipping sick Drake's a strong
maybe yeah yeah Brent might turn up
Brent is gonna turn up and just get
toxic fat he's gonna get toxic
it's gonna slap guys yeah so yeah head
on over there and get yourself patterned
um and Guys YouTube obviously subscribe
to the channel obviously there's a
million other people that did in fact
why didn't you facts ask yourself that
question while pressing the red button
audio listeners as always we appreciate
you we love you thank you so so so much
and if you could please please do us a
simple solid and leaving us a nice
review it's all we ask leave a nice
review five stars is obviously
preferable but whatever you say say it
with your chest and that's the end of
the introduction let's get into the
competitive aspect of the show today
Ellis has put his foot down and said
adamantly that he's gonna win today so
let's get on with top five five let's go
everybody grab your boards grab your
pens right guys top five this week is
drumroll please
top 5 most viewed YouTube videos ever oh
oh obviously as per
um let me know when you've locked in
um yeah I'll charge this one but I'm
gonna I'm charging it 100 Valiant effort
of course
I don't really know YouTube about that
yeah yeah yeah
over yourself I love it and this is you
want to relax a bit I am just a piece no
he's on two points he needs all the he
needs the bags daddy chill it's
Daddy tell
that's offensive
that's offensive can I name creators but
I don't know the name of the video that
they've dropped on YouTube I mean you
can you won't get the point
that wouldn't really make sense would
you ah bro never mind that's how how
much I've charged this week yeah cool Mr
confident Ellis will go with you first I
lie bro you better smack this go on in
bro okay so
me at the zoo
I've never even heard of that just you I
know you're gonna win just you wait did
you wait bro yeah
sneezing panda sneezing panda bear
Ouch Charlie I think it's good
Gangnam Style
it's a good one oh actually
funny fact
Gangnam Style broke the record for how
many views you can actually watch a
YouTube video and they had to alter it
Jesus just for that video just for that
video all right yeah so if that's not in
there I'll be I'll be very very much
confused the last one I'm a bit iffy
about is Mr B's Squig game because I
remember that was big but I don't know
maybe if it's gonna get in the top five
it might be a bit extreme Jimmy hmm Fair
well I'm actually not mad at myself
anymore okay I've gone squid game
oh cool I know squid game was the most
in 24 hours but I don't think it's been
around long enough to get in the top
five but that's all I can think about
okay I'm assuming Mr Beast Mr Beast is
good game I've done Gangnam Style I've
done Ouch Charlie hmm
yeah that was huge that was huge uh and
then the last two I've just done
Chocolate Rain
Chocolate Rain chocolate rain and I've
done um this one I know isn't in there
but it's all I can think of is that I
think it's called like bicycle Lanes is
it bike Lanes bicycles yeah yeah that
was big yeah I'm gonna do basketball
lines I don't know all right cool cool
uh ramps
um I've gone Mr BEAST's uh squid game
I've gotten another Mr Beast one with
that age game that he was played the
other day but it hasn't been around long
enough really
is that one one versus a hundred yeah
yeah I know which one you're talking
about yeah I'll just put one of us yeah
um
the MJ Thriller music video
um it's old but I don't think it's going
to be up there top five
um
Kanye West saying George Bush does not
like black people this can you tell how
much I was struggling here
you're saying some stuff though you're
talking that [__]
and uh yeah last one
X Games 2009 highlights
winging it
specifically what happened in 2009
um I just for me personally in my life
it was I remember being at school and it
just been the only thing everyone was
watching yeah and they've been really
like a thing that gassed me up so I
reckon let me say you were BMX around
that time as well yeah yeah yeah yeah
fair play fair play right number 10.
it's called learning Colors by mirashaki
TV with 4.91 billion views
number nine with 4.96 billion views Mark
Ronson Uptown Funk oh that would have
been a good one that would have been a
good one yeah Uptown Funk bro okay
number eight
cocoa lemon 5.36 million billion sorry
Wheels on the Bus oh bro coconut and
slaps on YouTube number seven
5.36 as well choo choo TV phonics with
songs with phonics songs with two words
yeah these baby ones go go crazy on
YouTube yeah number six with 5.94
billion Wiz Khalifa see you again wow
really yeah that did numbers after that
fast after my man died yeah and that
came on Fast whichever fast it was nine
remember that numbers yeah
no right number five with
6.02 billion views Ed Sheeran shape of
you
they're all going to be music videos
they're not just to all right all right
just a second just a second with
everybody they're not uh number four
6.26 billion views Coco lemon bath song
number three
6.73 billion views Lulu kids Johnny
Johnny yes papa Johny Johny yes papa
are you eating no papa
something like what telling lies no papa
open your mouth
I know about Johnny Johnny say less
Johnny Johnny yes papa yeah bro eating
cake no papa telling lies no papa open
your mouth
yeah Rob Johnny Johnny
that is hilarious all right number two
with 8.2 billion views uh despacito
oh wow man yeah makes sense oh yeah
and number one it's gonna be Gangnam
Style it has to be
with 13.01 billion views
baby shark
[Music]
baby shark I forgot about baby shark so
just to clarify you guys want none but
we will go
so just to clarify guiding himself was
number 11. oh okay 4.8 it has to be up
there it has to be up there so let me
see Gangnam Style you got Gangnam Style
you both both of them got Gangnam Style
so that's me out you got Gangnam Style
um who's next I'm rooting for you bro 12
Masher at the bear 13 uh Dame Tu cosita
I don't know what that is 14 Axel F 15
sugar Maroon 5 16 raw Kate Perry 17 One
Republic out in Stars 18 all music bro
Coco lemon baba black sheep 19 Justin
Bieber sorry 20 Shakira wakawaka
you said no it's not yeah but that was I
said
uh 10 to 10 to one or ten to one is
normal music I think I'm counting from
11 down because in the original ten to
one is
um is it not it is because even these
even these Coco melon ones they're all
music oh yeah true yeah yeah Johnny
Johnny is music I don't when I say music
I don't think about it like that but I
can't believe me
um funny enough I watched Mr BEAST's
most recent video the other day I got
one the no that's not the most recent
one his most recent one is the trains
he's got trains into a pit and I saw
obviously the views of what the squid
game ones was and it's 470 million it's
not hit a billion yeah it's not going to
be hitting in billions
um I think his new one his new one broke
up the record actually as well what for
most I think second most viewed or
whatever 24 hours yeah the yacht one
yeah oh the one versus one million
dollar yacht maybe I think so I think so
yeah that was Kmart I've maybe been last
month or so who did he try to beat I saw
that I can't remember who it was someone
I can't remember who's number one with
most views in it in 24 hours but yeah he
I watched the clip of someone saying
that he tried to obviously beat that
person but yeah I can't remember who it
was though oh it's Gangnam Style
yeah
yeah it's Gangnam Style the fact that oh
Charlie Bit Me got taken down barley
I've just seen it oh really so I've just
checked on historical most viewed videos
yeah and progression of most YouTube
videos most viewed YouTube um videos on
YouTube and so charlie bit me and then
said it got taken down Late July 2021
because it shows on a table and it says
the subheader says taken down oh okay
that got taken down apparently so that
would have been in there oh no it got no
he wouldn't have got 129 128.9 million
views oh damn
um
that's annoying
um I don't know what we do here to be
honest is it just top 20 that you've got
um it only goes to no it goes to
sorry it goes to 30. why didn't we pick
one from our list wait so what have you
so we've both got a good game both got
Ouch Charlie go for Gangnam Style okay
what have you got don't know so sneezing
panda man at the zoo me at the zoo
so let's just pick who's got the highest
views out of those four my two and your
two which video has the highest views
and one of us will win yeah so me at the
zoo has is it by George
is it an old school video
some white guy in a zoo literally she's
a white guy YouTube video 280 million
damn uh that's not a Wonder so that's 17
million seven
yeah 17. 17. cool James was Chocolate
Rain original 16 years ago by taizon day
yeah boy 136 million 136 million versus
what 2 is 280 yeah size one bicycle
Lanes I've never heard of that my life
okay you're nice Casey neistat I don't
know if it's called that but it's his
movies bike Lanes bicycle lane something
like that
by Casey neistat oh 12 12 um years ago
uh 29 M's okay so Ellis won that one
with 200 Days
by default let's go so that's three
points to Ellis finally let's go final
one three six nine yeah I believe damn
you fine I manifested that let's go
Alice geez big game imma give it to me
one more time get low low do you know I
just thought when I was doing the top
five I was thinking of the South Park
episode do you know when they do there's
loads of like YouTube Classics in the
episode yeah yeah yeah they go to like
YouTube's H quarter okay yeah and
there's olders yeah the Panda's in there
in it yeah remains in there as well
it's got the guy who's like leave
Britney Alone yeah that guy
that's jokes loads and stuff has he got
the um
the kid that's offended by people
offended him because he's Ginger sorry
because he got him what's that video
does this is that how completely
separate you um South Park episode oh I
don't know Cotman acts like he is the
kid who's who's Ginger and he's been
offended I think I've seen that one oh
man dad I don't know fair play all right
cool man well done this right babies
let's take a real quick break we need to
keep the lights on So today we're here
with a sponsor for your bouncing bundle
of joy come on my God
no we're not talking about a baby
we're talking about your baby makers
come on that's right today's show is
brought to you by manscapes but just
like babies your delicate little guys
have sensitive skin and deserve products
that are not only skin safe but made
with safe ingredients that's where
madscape's Platinum package comes in
from razors to shower care this package
goes above the gold standard for your
body hair so treat your beautiful boys
to the world's finest toys at
manscape.com
manscape.com and use our very super
duper exclusive never heard before code
which is sng Sierra November gold and
that's going to get you a cheeky 20 off
plus free shipping one more time for the
top head on over to madscape.com user
code sng Sierra November gold 20 off and
free shipping let's get out of the
episode thank you very much
um right I've got a thread for us
[Music]
down
that's a lot so the sweat drips down my
balls skate Skates
skating in that to the top of our voices
you know yeah
drips down my balls that's wild oh
Escape skates
yeah there's a Banger Banger Right This
Thread yeah yeah we've done um similar
ones before yeah so it's just kind of
like a re-up it's like a throwback
episode but it's um it's resurfaced okay
um and some of the comments were too
funny bro so pettiest reason to stop
talking to a girl
okay so this one's resurfaced we've
definitely done this one before okay
when she arrived at mine she called her
baby daddy to say she was safe this is
the threat I was gonna do I think
let's run it back to back all right
this is the same one I'm Ghast
because it's sweetened me I was oh I
think I read something I literally
bellowed yeah bro I had to cover my
mouth yeah I was laughing that much yeah
much yes gang let's go all right calm
you're right you go you go you go she
was shaking the time
this is going to make me laugh bro she
was shaking the table while cutting a
steak I will never forget
bottle that's disgusting
Jesus Christ yeah yeah clinking of the
glass not yuck
uh you got more going on sorry bro
um
she said teeth and feets bro that's bars
heaths and feet as far as come on man
these hurt my feet
she didn't have any furniture in her
apartment whatsoever
down bro fam she took off her
she took off her wit
she took off her wig to eat crabs legs
[Laughter]
she must have been dripping from bam
dripping that butter dip had it on the
roads
that's too funny bro she didn't bless me
when I sneezed
oh bro
she asked me to talk normal and stop
using such big words oh my God that's
disgusting
she says she wanted to go somewhere
exotic like Atlanta or Miami
oh God I'm sweating bro but I'm this one
Sweeting me she had green earring backs
what green earring backs bro oh that's
Rusty my God that's Rusty and covered in
algae I'm surprised her earlob didn't
fall off oh bro that's infection jeez
she never combed her daughter's hair
oh my god
um she didn't like water I saw that one
red flag man that's a lot of women red
flags there's a lot of women don't like
water this one she squeezed my
toothpaste in the middle like a damn
Savage that will draw me that would jump
oh my God damn Savage bro
she kissed with her eyes open
I literally literally just read that bro
felt like she was gonna levitate
oh oh
her walk by air wasn't pleasant
Jesus Raw
that's just that's disgusting bro walk
by oh what that after that after whiff
yeah a walk by air fam this one killed
me she had big gums and lowercase teeth
lower case bro that's a that's a piss
take lower case consonant teeth
her son
[Laughter]
that right there
because kids don't know
control they don't oh yeah he would have
broke the skin facts hundred percent
with a broken skin you're laughing it
off oh my God punish him uh last one for
me
so sweet in me the smell of her weave
gave me a stomachache that's yeah that's
not cool the smell of the weave gave me
a stomach cold I'll do one more as well
she didn't have braids under her wig
just a James Brown perm
that's just hair on hair yeah
just hair on hair
Plus
stressful and disgusting inside of her
microwave was dirty as [__] that's the
last time I do that's a Telltale that oh
your microwave is filled with that glass
door is just splattered I can't trust
yeah
[Music]
yo let's go
let's get let's get it Subway offers
free sandwiches for life
um contest if you legally change your
name to Subway right I've seen this oh
bro I've not seen this American food
chain uh Subway has launched a free
sandwiches for Life contest for anyone
willing to change their name to Subway
The Sandwich Company announced the start
of their new competition this week with
a desirable Delhi hero prize
uh one fortuitous winner would legally
change their name to Subway will be
picked to get a free stacked meat double
cheese subs for the rest of their life
from August 1st to 4th
any adult can go online Subway
namechange.com to enter the to enter and
potentially win a lifetime of Delhi
Heroes somebody's looking forward to
reward its biggest fan with free subs
for life if they legally change their
name the announcement came on the
company's website
um and it read Subway brand Subway brand
loves and love and dedication runs deep
especially when free sandwiches are up
for grabs all fees associated with
change in the Winner's name will be
covered by the company but the winner
must consent to a background check and
provide company with proof they changed
their name with four months of being
picked then they will receive fifty
thousand dollars in Subway gift cards so
it's not free Subway for life
it doesn't make you feel like [__]
out of all the fast foods chains and
stuff if I had to pick one get rid of
all it'd be Subway because it's so
versatile versatile It's banging it's
not bro what do you order
I'll get a different one every time so
you're a liar yeah
I guess like if you're not a liar then
you're [__] up what do you mean you
get a different one every time every
time no I mean like I mix it up so like
I'll have an Italian BMT I like that one
yeah
I like tuna melt
uh meatball Mariana obviously yeah
banging
um I've actually tried the steak one but
I want steak and cheese is nice steak
and cheese I want to try it yeah it's
clean
um
what ones do I have I can't remember
some other ones but my go-to are like
meatball tuna or um BLT yeah yeah I had
a um I had a Subway the other day
[__] hate subway man I do this it's
falling off yeah it is
I don't know if they've changed the
toasting method as well that [__] just
crumbles yeah it just crumbles bro yeah
overheated yeah dry but it depends on
the bread as well true I don't ever get
hot um Italian not hot Italian
now bro [__] subway man I love it the
cookies slap yeah the cookies
I'll give them Subway that's cookies
yeah but the cookies are bag yeah but
yeah those rainbow dorms yeah they were
nice yeah and the Macadamia ones Jesus
yeah they slap bro but um Subway as a as
a franchise overall I think it sucks I
used to love it when we were kids dance
onto the meatballs because that's not
meat anymore oh damn they're outside
into it I had it a few years ago that's
not meat anymore it is they have they
have a vegan alternative now
it tastes the same yeah the vegan tastes
like the real one yeah that Nando's wrap
bro I was oh yeah
I didn't even know yeah honestly some of
it now is crazy it made me think for a
second a couple bites in
but until
Megan was like someone's eating my vegan
my vegan wrap who's got it and I looked
at the wrap the the label which was Tiny
by the way Nando's fixed that
um yeah I had no idea so damn yeah the
alternatives are real yeah I'm not I'm
not on it bro that's stuff like that
scares me yeah but if I'm saying if I
put the two the real and the fake right
next to each other and you you tried
both of them
I'm not sure I believe you all right I
just it scares me because I'm like what
are you doing to it to make it taste
exactly like a chicken some of it goes
way too far like they're doing now
um
I don't know why it's in the kitchen we
had someone come in and Pitch to us at
their vegan food and she was doing a 3D
printed steak
yeah they're doing so it's like you can
have it medium rare and it's vegan but
you can have it like they did like fake
blood in it and [__] oh Jesus it's weird
as hell would you Manny um this is oh
this is a this is a good um
this is a good question for would you
call it
um
ethics right this will test your ethics
okay would you
um
change over would you stop eating animal
meat
if they had a similar conversation if
they started doing lab growing me would
you change over to lab growing no chance
would I change over to lab lab grown
meat so the the meat is exactly the same
but it's grown in the last it's grown in
a lab but and the the thing is is that
it doesn't need to be killed now it's
exactly the same steak so a fillet of
the lab grow meat is exactly the same as
a fillet of beef it's still never made a
difference you'd never know the
difference it's exactly the same it's a
protein content is the protein in the
content is the same everything's safe
it's the D they're using the DNA from
cows to grow the Flesh of a cow without
actually having to grow a live animal
that needs to be killed it's just their
growing flesh so it's like same as if
you needed like a heart transplant and
they were able to make you a new heart
it's exactly the same as your heart they
take your DNA they use the cells that
needed and they create it and they put a
heart in you it's the same thing so they
would make lab growing meat that's
exactly the same um it doesn't come from
a real animal this is a laboratory
animal that they've made that never was
alive so ethically they've not had to
kill anything yeah and then would you
switch over to that um I'd probably do
it for like a week I wouldn't switch
over permanently I just know that for a
fact you can't tell the difference I
know probably I would the only reason I
would know I I would probably tell the
difference is the pricing I'm assuming
the pricing will be higher at first it
will be higher but then eventually once
they Mass produce it yeah once it
becomes normalized once becomes
normalized this is the swing then real
animals will become higher in price
because they'll be but then like
so let me ask everyone and then I'll say
what I was gonna say what would you do
switch you'll switch and then you'll
switch back I think I'll switch to try
and I'll probably end up switching back
what would you do yeah I don't I don't
think I would
um
I don't think I would so you can stay
without a context if they just replaced
all meat without saying anything cool
but like just knowing that it's growing
in a lab it just freaks me out a bit so
what would you say when the protesters
are stopping you in the street
and they're like
you would rather actually kill stuff
just for just because you're like oh it
makes me feel a bit I personally
wouldn't kill stuff I wouldn't kill it
but no but I'm saying like if you the
only reason animals are now getting
killed in this scenario in my opinion
I'm playing Devil's Africa I'm not
judging you okay I'm just saying what
Twitter would say yeah yeah
well you've then in this scenario now
you are the only now the only reason
animals are getting killed because in
this dystopian world we have the
facilities now to completely eradicate
killing animals we have meat is exactly
the same and the only reason we are now
killing animals and taking their lives
away and taking babies from their mums
and mums from their babies is because
you man feel a bit uncomfortable about
lab grown [__] yeah I mean I would say
it's not natural but I know they would
say it's not natural the way we do stuff
in the meat industry but I don't know I
just don't like the thought of it's just
it's really not natural it's going the
[__] completely the other way like
it's just it's not meat is it it you
might say it is but it's not I'm with
Ellis Brothers I don't know mentally I
think mentally you all [__] with me it's
a mentally thing if like I said if they
just did it if they just said
you know oh we're replacing no if they
didn't say it sorry if they just
replaced all meat right cool like I'll
have it but I think it's just knowing
that it's going in love it'll just make
me feel uneasy cool I'd probably go
vegan oh really I'd probably go vegan if
they were if they said like all meat now
artificial I'll be like [__] that right
absolutely that's gonna be fascinating
yeah because yeah I would that's very
interesting what are you
if they got rid of yeah but uh in the
scenario of like if they got if they
took away all
uh meat from a natural animal and said
it's all being replaced now
from a lab to a lab grow meat how would
you yeah I'd I'd have to just charge it
yeah I won't go vegan my bro I'm not
lying to anyone you'd have to because
you're not eating meat anymore
I wouldn't go vegan I'll just charge it
but mentally I think it would it would
have a it would take a toll on me for a
little bit and then I'd probably go over
it what's your answer
I don't think it would bother me in the
slightest obviously the first time yeah
I'd be a bit like oh this is weird but
then immediately as long as it tastes
the same Texas same everything's the
same it genuinely even bother me fair
enough and yeah it's like yeah it
wouldn't bother me at all fair enough I
think it's a psyche thing but yeah it is
yeah
um but then I think like this these
things like because I always get
interested when it's when it comes to
the whole like oh this is
um weird it's not normal it's not
natural and all those kind of things and
I think about there's a million things
that happen in everyday life that's not
natural yeah if you take a look at
[__] twins a lot like identical twins
are when like there was one egg
and like the sperm went in and then
somewhere along the line the [__] split
in two and now you have two things that
are exactly the same one of these joins
ain't real bro
these [__] ain't real bro it's not
natural bro why these [__]
ain't real deep it like that well yeah
but we just get on with it yeah we just
we see two people that look exactly the
same except it and we charge it yeah
yeah one of those [__] ain't real
they're real fast
that's not natural yeah one's a
prototype yeah bro one's an accident
yeah facts about one of them because
like one of these twins was the original
yeah one is missing one has less satin
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's exactly
the same as if like I had magical powers
and I just grabbed your arm off you and
then threw it on the floor and it grew
into another fuhad
it's exactly the same bro
and then your arm grew back
and they're like everyone were like this
[__] ain't real yeah yeah yeah
everyone will be on my side just say
this [__] her in real because it happens
in in Tom
and then eventually there will be a
small subsection of society that are
like now I want to have animals and
everyone's gonna be like what the [__]
is gonna be riots
it's going to be worldwide like upset
for these like 10 of sick [__] that are
willing to pay 200 pounds for a real
steak yes if when it gets to stupid
stuff like that I'm obviously gonna eat
the lab [__] you know what I mean but
you freaked me at that time when you
said obviously I think we debunked it
when you said broccoli was grown oh yeah
yeah
I don't want to [__] well luckily it
was why does the lab stuff bother you
though it just freaks me out man it's
not bro if we were actually to watch the
documentaries about just animal meat in
general oh yeah
yeah yeah they have to think they're
pregnant so they inject them with
hormones every day that make them think
they're pregnant that's the only reason
they're able to milk cows
but it makes perfect sense why would the
cow keep producing milk yeah
now a cow is like a human bro yeah it
only produces
move on because I want to eat meat pause
pause pause pause pause I need to eat my
chicken my meat somebody all right you
saw me right here
yeah [__] with me
um back to the subway thing jargons
threatened to legally change their name
for that is mine say that's uh there's
some uh professional boxer chick who's
willing to do it she said on her
Instagram if she gets 40 000 likes so
she's down horrendously she's doing this
for the likes
a female boxers doing this for likes let
me find give me 40 000 likes and I'll do
it what are these likes gonna get you
bro Stevie uh Levy
um post social media challenge to change
the names so free sandwich promotion she
said she'll change her name to Subway if
post reaches 40 000 likes on Instagram
that's why you call being down
horrendously bro she's down bad I mean
she's got the bat signal on her chest so
she's been down bad bro horrifically
um but yeah that's that wow yeah that's
tough
30 so she's on her way out she knows the
likes she does need the likes boys yeah
I was gonna say a thousand likes and
I'll legit do it but my mate has advised
me to make it 40 000.
um because it's unlikely
oh Jesus man Jesus Christ indeed get a
life seriously cool man um you wanted to
read something to us confession time
slash fetish so I've been going to the
gym for around eight years now and I
have achieved a phys I've achieved a
physique that tends to attract a lot of
women the thing is I strictly date women
who weighs more than more or less 250
pounds what's that in kg
that's like 120 kg bro 220 kg about half
it yeah yeah yeah so I'll read a bit
again the thing is I strictly date women
who weigh more or less 250 pounds
fatties in general I tried to make the
relationship last around two months
before she feels comfortable enough to
start going to the uh to start working
out with me
don't get me wrong I generally spend
time with them buy them nice things make
them feel loved but my sole intention is
to get them to come to the gym with me
this could go on for months up until the
point where she actually loses weight
and starts to attract other guys
I have helped some women lose so much
weight that they end up cheating on me
with their own with their new found
boosted confidence which is um which is
really what I was hoping to so which is
really what I'm hoping would happen 100
of the time my goal is for them to get
attractive and leave me so that I can
move on to the next fatty and make her
lose weight am I out here doing God's
work or am I going to hell I'm generally
curious
whoa whoa so long story short he dates
fat girls for the sole purpose of them
going finally going to the gym with him
stem starting to lose weight them start
to gain confidence and eventually
cheering on him leaving him so he can
move on to the next fight
he enjoyed this in fact he said
confession time slash fetish he loves
this man said I'm a sick [__] I like a
sick [__]
[Music]
that's his face is kink my bro he loves
it
um this guy's like a Batman villain yeah
well this
is he doing God's work or is he going to
hell thoughts
um I mean I mean with if we're hey I
don't want to be this guy with all due
respect with all due respect
they are willing to go Jimmy forcing no
one to do nothing okay so he's clearly
attracted to these women
because he's banging them he's clearly
attracted to them
at their current state
he doesn't find them unattractive he's
not shaming them in any way he likes
them
he's
manipulative and
extremely as a sicko
um
but
bro
it sounds like they're choosing to go
gym
and if they choose to go gym and they
like it and then they lose all this
weight like being with someone for two
months and then deciding like two months
is not long enough to decide to
completely change your life yeah and
like lose a hundred pounds yeah yeah
like that's not enough so
I think in his I think his intentions if
we're speaking purely actions versus
intentions his intentions are going to
send him to hell yeah because his
intention is to force someone to fall in
love with them yeah and get him to do
something that wasn't their idea to do
and they're only doing it based on their
emotion with him I'm pretty sure that is
a form of trafficking if what I heard
about when Andrew Tate was getting in
trouble for the human trafficking stuff
I think a lot of it was him saying his
plan to make girls become cam girls was
that he would date them
make them fall in love with him oh wow
and then tell them I've got this
business I think you'd be really good at
it and because they were in love with
him they would agree to do it and
they'll become cam girls so oh wow so so
I don't know if that's the whole story
got done for a lot but there was a thing
when he was getting accused of
um like sex trafficking girls human
trafficking girls he was like obviously
not obviously not obviously not and then
one of the things that got pulled up was
a paragraph
um from his like website where he said
this was the plan I'd use and they would
say it's called like
um
it's called like pretty boy or like
Prince Charming or this is like a type
of thing for it
um where it is a form of trafficking wow
yes it's dark yeah yes
very very dark bro so
um under that pretense this is like a
similar format is that like I want this
girl to do this so in order to do that
I'm going to approach her date her make
her fall in love with me and then get
her to do this thing even though I'm
quote unquote doing this for her
um
yeah it's [__] up
it's hella [__] up he's [__] up I
had already I was like damn yes that is
a that is a fetish it's a crazy crazy
fetish
um but I'm hoping there's a significant
percentage of them that's like I'm cool
bro I want to go gym [__] hopefully
that's the case he doesn't seem to be
talking about them once I wonder what
happens then
you just lock someone I guess it just
moves on hmm
mad damn yeah I had to read that out all
right fair play right we got a limited
finisher yes sir how to tell your
husband you lost 350 000 pounds
I've been married to my husband for 20
years we have a good marriage here's the
context of him he's very stingy with his
money he's very money orientated and
rather slit his wrists than give him
then give money away or spend money on
things he let me control the bank
accounts and all the money and I started
investing
um in the stock market and lost the
money
I tried to invest it I tried to invest
them back in to try and recoup my losses
and paid for teachers and courses
anyways time goes on and before I know
it I've lost 350k he has no idea if I
tell him he'd probably divorced me it's
been over a year and he has no idea he
regularly asks for bank statements to
see his money to see um his money is
there but I'm a wizard with the
computers so I make them myself and he's
none the wiser Jesus I don't sleep I
don't eat
and he's going to find out as soon as he
wants he's going to find out as he wants
to move somewhere and I have no idea how
I'm going to get that money back what do
I do I feel like I'm drowning please
please help me [__] drown
that's my that's my advice sharp and
drown bro bro face the music I don't eat
I don't sleep
over a year is a piss take fam if you've
if you've swindled all my money and
you've been swindling me for a year and
not telling me and I've been asking you
bank statements this back the same as
that and you're just you're lying to me
in them frauding me yeah we would I
would take you to court yeah and then I
will take everything else you have yeah
facts because you can't you just can't
do that yeah like the thing is this is
it's a stupid thing like obviously she
loves Donnie but yeah like
you lost my money once
you should have told me Fox you then
lost it again should have told me you
shouldn't have even had the opportunity
to lose it again because I should have
come in there and been like turns out
you don't know what you're doing right
and that's fine you tried yeah yeah you
failed I love you for trying yeah but
you [__] it never again with my money
yeah yeah but we're okay yeah I love you
for trying we're okay you bottled it
and got courses and teachers on the
stock exchange which is a hustle in
itself and lost 350 bags
you deserve to get divorced 100 I'm
sorry drown then in it 100 there's no if
buts or maybes yeah that's not yeah that
just face the music regardless of
whatever percentage of um richness you
are in the world that is a significant
amount of money a hundred percent any
human being on this planet 100 350
000 pounds yes it's it's too much bro
it's game over I'm sorry it's game over
like you're done you're done in this
house facts facts 350. and I want to
move somewhere now I'm gonna find out
that I can't I wouldn't know how to
I wouldn't know how to tell my family
that my life is over because of my
ex-wife oh bro you know what I mean she
stole all my money invested it without
my consent I've got nothing lost
everything I've got no pockets she took
everything she literally took everything
and she said she was doing me a favor
that's long wow that's long
um but yeah that's that all right guys
thank you very much for today that was
juicy
um we had some highs we had some lows we
had some deep so we had some shallows
um as always head over to patreon.com
Juicy stuff coming up
um and yeah love love
[Music]
thank you